[Musique]
des tenues numéro 742 affecté au bloc 2
essayons de rédiger ce dictionnaire
depuis 20 ans c'est pourquoi je propose
que le grand est peu conventionnel
monsieur marc en soit la solution ainsi
que notre soleil c'est un gigantesque
est impossible il y à un moyen
on leur demandera de lire de chercher
les mots que l'on veut et qui les
écrivent sur des petits bouts de papier
vous êtes ce brave docteur ravi de vous
connaître en personne à y croire nous
sommes partenaires m'ont pour man
toute ma vie tout ce que j'ai accompli
c'était pour préparer cela
[Musique]
vous croyez que je suis fou vous avez
vraiment peur pour votre vie les sims
pour plus de livres
fruit de notre collaboration mais ce
n'est quelques ans
[Musique]
william mineur sera privé de toute
reconnaissance à quoi tu super
qu'un homme mauvais puis se racheter
martin si vous considérez que chaque
individu reçoit mérite vraiment une
chance il perd elle aussi noël moral
quand juge je peux mais va t de cet
endroit à travers les livres je me suis
envolé au bout du monde grâce à la
lecture
[Musique]
nous sommes désormais liège comme des
frères un américain un écho scène un
d'oxford
un deuil est un génie et à fo mais qui
des deux est le jci monsieur murray
nouveau surveillant nous sommes quelque
peu inquiet surveillez donc vous serez
très surpris
[Musique]